Lu Wolfson professor of communications
at American University and author of a
new book the untapped power of the press
what kind of job is the American press
doing today well if you look at the job
it was doing 10-15 years ago you'd say
it's wonderful progress there are things
being done now that are on America's
front pages that are on the evening news
that were never there ten years ago and
that a lot of people in journalism said
wouldn't be there but there are also
things that aren't there that ought to
be there what would you say if all that
what should be there that's not there
today in my book I write about why don't
we tell people more about what
government is really like get inside of
a tell about the decision-making process
do it in an interesting way that catches
their eye and that really explains to
them what is going on in Washington what
those people in Washington are doing to
you to us and why and I think that's a
way to do it okay I'm going to be
talking with mr. Lou Wolfson tonight let
me show you his book the untapped power
of the press which came out a several
months ago and as he was seeing it now
being reviewed across the country in a
number of newspapers and and various TV
shows as well amen okay for those of you
who are who are interested in the in the
press you say it applies to people who
are journalists as well as non
journalists Michael sure absolutely and
certainly there's a wider and wider
audience of people who are interested to
know what are the news media all about
what makes them tick let's talk for a
minute about the news media in
Washington I think as I say in your book
here they're about 4,000 of us now which
is a lot of people it may be larger I
saw one count this week that said 10,000
depends on how you count them I suppose
if you counted all the mini cameras we
see now here and added everybody up
there'd be a lot of us where do most
journalists concentrate in Washington on
the news I mean do they focus on the
White House do they focus on Congress I
mean do they pick one spot that really
demands everyone's attention or or Gary
well I think there is a focus as you
know there's a focus on the White House
and Congress I mean you're going to see
more stories about what the president
doesn't says and also following Congress
because that's where a lot of the
decision-making is initiated but there
are other stories
that get less attention and that is for
example the agencies that bureaucracy
journalists are now covering these but
they once looked at them and their eyes
glazed over and said you know we don't
want to know what goes on in all those
cubby holes in government and yet in
those cubby holes and governments the
decisions that are made in the White
House and Congress are pursued the
decisions are often changed policy gets
shaped and when it gets down to
grassroots it may be something entirely
different
why have journalists stayed away from
some of some of the agencies too
technical or it takes to difficult just
to find their way through the masses of
people to the people who are making the
decisions journalist instincts are to go
for a breaking story to begin with when
journalists when a journalist goes to
work each day and this isn't true of all
journalists every day many are very
thoughtful but they don't say gee I
think I'm going to explain this about
what goes on in government today what
they say is I wonder what's going to
happen today and that's why there's this
concentration on breaking news you get
caught up on it it's easy to get our
easier to get a story it's easier to get
attention for your story your byline you
get on your face on television and there
are demands from your editors and your
producers as to which kinds of stories
will be most attractive and sell not
selling the sense of for money but sell
be easiest to see and watch and and
understand and as a result they shy away
from getting into the processes of
government a lot you don't get in and
see how decisions are made go back and
say well why why did we get this tax
reform what really happened what what
we're on what caused this series of
events don't you sometimes have to have
a lot of people in order to do that
because you still have to cover the
breaking story and sometimes if you're
covering the breaking story isn't that
harder to take to be able to step back
at the same time and try to do the
larger picture why does everybody have
to cover the same breaking story though
that's my question we have all kinds we
have wire services we have combinations
of news organizations the Los Angeles
Times in the Washington Post have a news
service
the New York Times other newspapers and
we have these combinations and yet
everybody kind of sweeps along going for
the same stories and yet papers get four
or five someone get four or five
different versions of the same story
coming into the news organization every
night now true one news organization may
do a little better than the other one
reporter may do a little bit on the
other but it's marginal meantime there's
an awful lot of things that aren't
covered I think the the biggest problem
is there is a kind of a feeling in
Washington in the press corps gee that
stuff is not interesting people don't
want to know about it and it's hard to
make it interesting and yet there are
are news organizations as you know who
are beginning to do this and they are
the ones who are most admired by other
by their peers as to say I wish we could
do that kind of thing mm-hmm what's your
opinion of the caliber of journalists
who cover Washington I have a very good
opinion a very strong opinion I think
they're very good I think today's
journalists are brighter than they were
certainly in my generation I was in the
press corps a while back and you know we
were rather timid about a lot of things
we never had a great deal of curiosity
about a lot of things that young
journalists today have and a lot of them
are frustrated because of this because
they're smart they know there are
stories that ought to be told and yet
they don't get the opportunity to do it
and there's a lot of reasons for it it
isn't just the reporters fault
it's how decisions are made by their
editors and their producers it's
economic pressures that sort of thing
there's a combination of things when you
mentioned that all those of us who
reporters have to deal every day with
our editors who are very good people and
have very good very good sense of what's
going on and have to coordinate a lot of
reporters in an office how do you get a
reply mean how would you go about today
getting a redditor interested in the
subject which he might be not in the
mainstream of Washington might be a
technical issue or something how does a
reporter use do you talk about them
being frustrated how do they do they
what's your advice to them about getting
their stories told or finding ways to
tell new stories I have a sense in
is easy for me coming from my ivory
tower but I have a sense that almost any
story in Washington affects people and
that's how to sell those stories is to
show what is the effect on people what
is the effect of a decision made by the
Food and Drug Administration that maybe
some dull dried decision about a drug
that's obscure we don't know about it
but people take that drug and there may
be side effects and there are all sorts
of things that can flow from a very
obscure story that's buried in the
paperwork and buried in the process and
buried in the decision-making what do
you think the the public's chief
criticisms of the press are today the
public's chief criticisms right oh I
don't know it's hard to say there's a
lot of unease in the news media about
people questioning the credibility of
news organizations I think the public is
very uneasy about the fact that
television in particular has changed how
much the media affect their lives we're
constantly watching the news we're
listening to it we're reading about it
and they're part of it and but what
bothers people most of all I think is
they don't understand how the news media
work and I say that in my book I think
that's the chief problem is they really
don't understand and they don't
understand some very elementary things
about the press and how it works
especially in Washington and it's kind
of unfortunate because it could be
explained to them I've seen and
explained I've seen public officials
I've taught public officials in fact who
didn't understand about the press that
were as ignorant about it as an ant the
average citizen and when you started to
explain basic things they say oh we
didn't know the reporter had to go
through all that to write a story okay
now is your time it's Christmas Eve to
sit back I hope you power your shopping
done your packages react you can talk
about newspapers and journalism and and
how you think the press might do a
better job or some of the criticisms you
might have you know of your own papers
or are the people that that
see or watch cover the news let's take a
call now from Orange Texas you're on
c-span go ahead the media cover the
events in exactly the same way you'll
find exactly the same features humored
stories you know everywhere if you don't
get coverage it's so much well we may
have an agreement but we also may have a
disagreement because it's a question of
degree I think there's a great deal of
diversity in American news media no I
don't think we should lose sight of that
we still have a free press we have
people saying things that others don't
say we like it that way and that's the
way it should be I think there's a great
deal variety but you're right also
there's a great deal of copycat
journalism if you will and that's not
good and a press that often prides
itself on its independence
quite often doesn't realize that there
is a lack of real competition what do
you what do you think accounts for what
you for the copycat journal journalism
just that there are so many reporters
and there are only so many key stories
in the course of one day well it's also
a kind of a safety in that we have
something here in Washington and many
people probably heard about her at
journalism with a heard goes after the
same story and there is safety in the
herd in part that self imposed by
reporters but in part it's imposed by
their editors because the journalist who
is really independent and strikes out on
his or her own and does a story that's
off the main story will get questioned
well everybody's covering that one over
there what are you doing covering that
story over there it's very true and I'm
just thinking of one of the my most
recent experience if I heard journalism
when was when Prince Charles and
Princess Diana were here
I've never stand we've had I think there
and I went down to Florida with him I
think there were 500 reporters
credentialed
and you waited for hours just to see
them come and go and no one said
anything and very little happened and
everybody had very little to write about
but we were all there there's nothing to
say
the summit conference in Geneva is
another example look at all the report
and I talked to reporters who went there
and they said I don't know why I went
but I wanted to be there and they all
came up with essentially the same thing
all of us and good analysis they could
do some of them could do but how many of
those reporters will cover nuclear
policy week in and week out or go back
to it they won't they'll go on to
something else one of the key areas that
everyone focuses here on Washington is
the presidency is that ik is that an
example of what you considered her
journalism well I think the people who
live in the White House heard feel often
feel very unhappy because they feel so
restricted from what they can cover and
so manipulate it because with this
ministration in particular you have a
very a president who's well-liked who's
very skillful at public relations and as
a result they are able to put things out
of the White House that make the
president look good and they are able to
play down the unhappy things and that
frustrates the White House press corps
and they're kept kind of caged up in
their press room a good deal at a time
so that in that sense they give a lot of
coverage we get a lot of attention for
the president but they feel frustrated
about what they can say I say in my book
and this is a case of untapped power to
a high degree I think that there are all
kinds of stories that you can go after
to see how presidential decisions have
been made and that we ought to know
about and forget about the superficial
what happened today stand up on the
White House lawn or whatever okay let's
take a call now from Chicago you're on
the air go ahead yes ma'am mom I'm very
intrigued with the gentleman's book I
will be one of his customers as far as s
all right my name is mr. Schad I'm from
Algonquin Illinois a suburb of Chicago
is it cold out there
very my question is I am I have a
personal experience with the
with the media and the press and an
income tax trial in the summer of 1984
in Arizona and my question is why is
that it seems like an established fact
that what the media puts out on a tax
trial are the results and it seems like
it's always a press release that the
Internal Revenue Service has put out
rather than a non-biased report of
actually what happened and the case
well you've hit on another aspect of
reporting of government which is
reporting on the courts and there are
great weaknesses in that the kinds of
stories that interest the news media are
usually more sensational stories
obviously ones that have to do with
crime or at the top of the list it's an
interesting experience here I know some
reporters in Washington when I was
reporting which was quiet nobody covered
tax court now more and more reporters
are covering it because there are
interesting stories there to cover you
need a reporter who's going to take
initiative and go after that sort of
thing but you're right they don't
ordinarily cover it in the process
unless something is very sensational and
sticks out and then a few will flock
there we also live in a city where we
have untold press releases coming out of
government committees and that
occasionally in the rush or perhaps some
if there's some extra space one day that
you might find someone rewriting a press
release but there's may happen
fascinating stories in tax court and
those reporters who have gone after them
have come up with some wonderful story
okay let's go across the country now
perhaps a warmer climate going to
Palmdale California going in fact they
are like every other person who doesn't
know everything about what they're
talking about they report on things
and resolving something like I was
mm-hmm listen to their reports read him
in the paper you find out that they
really don't know what they're talking
about they're just making news well I
can say that in one sense you're you're
right they often tell are incomplete in
their reporting but I don't really agree
with you I don't think the reporters I
know the ones that are really
conscientious and that's the rank and
file of American journalists - are
really trying hard to get at the news
and they're trying hard to tell a
foolish story if they can your
experience is a common one and many
people that are watching and listening
now probably have had that well GRE
those stories and I'm not so sure about
it because I remember a story I was
involved in and they got it all wrong
well people read and watch news stories
with different kinds of perceptions they
like to have themselves look good in the
news story or their organization look
good and that's not always going to be
the case often they want things to be
complete they want almost a journal
written about it rather than just a news
story written about it and that's not
going to happen either so a journalist
has a heavy burden which is to try to
distill down the news tell a mass
audience about it and be faithful to it
and they don't always succeed it's a
very imperfect profession tell me what
profession you're in sir ask him about
what his what he's experienced my point
was there are a lot of imperfect
professions around ok let's go now to
Kansas City Missouri you're on the air
go ahead hello Michael
nope well ok ok
[Applause]
with your topic this evening about the
earth journalism and I hate to bring
this up again but never left this is
what I've been trying to get in about is
the vote on the tax bill that everyone
was so irate about some were claiming
that Tip O'Neill gaveled off too fast
and others were claiming that he did not
etc etc now let me begin by saying I'm a
c-span junkie I taped the whole thing
from beginning to end and I reviewed it
at least four times and in the places
where the controversies were at least a
dozen matters
so if I may take about 30 seconds in the
beginning there was the rule the rule
which was originally turned down was
change minutely but there was an
addition to the room making it possible
for mr. Michel to introduce a Liva was a
sense of the House Resolution which had
to do with the timing of the tax pit
okay I'm gonna speed you up here let's
get to your question well I can't get to
the question I'm tonight hey get to the
logical progression well hurry up
because I've got to give a lot of other
projects run too so let's go from there
to the end of the tax bill when Tip
O'Neill
did what
usually does which is alright there's no
problem there but I heard journalists
and I chick rim to say it was on c-span
who claimed that he was calling for
somebody to ask for a vote what he did
was he called for the vote he passed it
he wrapped it off with the other end of
his gavel not the heavy let's hurry up
now cuz I'm gonna have to cut you off
real quick he called for mr. Michael to
bring up his what was made made in order
by the rule to bring up his timing well
now what's your question real quick why
why do we as this not been reported ok
they said that he was calling for mr.
Michael - okay try that I think that I'm
not sure but I think they had to do with
it was a record vote or a voice vote and
I don't know because I didn't watch it
you've got the advantage on me but I
want to say that I think the reporting
of the tax reform legislation is some of
the best reporting and I've seen in
journalism because it does go in the
process it's an interesting fact the
washing not to be parochial but the
Washington Post had a story in the last
two days which was actually called a
process story in which they explained
that things are going to be different in
the Senate from the house because the
house has very tight rules and when
things get out in the floor there aren't
a lot of things you can do in the Senate
there's going to be a lot of amendments
and the whole process changes and that
changes the effect on the legislation so
I think the press is very good at that
sort of thing when it's a big major
piece of legislation okay let's go now
to Malibu California
you're on c-span thank you
anyway absolutely Malibu and I certainly
can cure I'm gonna get your book but
notice I watch c-span all of the time
and CNN because I think they do the best
reporting when I turn over to those
networks I have noticed such a
difference in the last several years
particularly ABC they use the same
sources when they want interviews they
have the same people over and over again
Koppel has toned down or even if there's
a topic you would think he would covered
than the top of that day it's not
covered that night where it used to be
but I want to get to one of the things
that bothered me that the showman you
know the that wonderful news reporter on
the time was dumped from the time
because he was covering corruption in
New York City and there was no more said
about it but you know who I mean
children I can't think of his name and I
know what you're he was all developments
going on in New York another thing is
the then of course the Sacramento PD had
a story on lack soul and they got dress
dress because they don't have that kind
of insurance they could report the story
so they backed off okay do you have a
quick question wrapping all this up
yes I'm wondering why except for CNN and
few of our local stations have not
covered it's terrible homelessness and I
don't mean they're drunks okay you mean
okay well you know you know they've
antigen me but III think that's being
covered very heavily where I live it is
a story being covered
a great deal here in Washington but you
know one of the points you hit on about
newspapers pulling back on
investigations that's a problem because
there is a resurgence of libel suits
people are trying to get at newspapers
by using libel suits as a weapon and
that's another side of the press's
relationship with government we have to
always be wary about that those of you
who've out there who wonder sometim
about the Free Press and whether or not
not to be controlled let me I can't say
trust trust me but let me guarantee to
you that we're better having a Free
Press that isn't being controlled
imperfect as it may be okay let's go now
to Southfield Michigan go ahead you're
on yes go ahead my arrack political
group and they were talking about you
notice my case the reasons my case and
they're kind of put pressure on our
state department any more information
against Israel but what I like to
suggest as a favor to me as being a
[ __ ] caller that the big s would would
get the press to print a story of how
how the Arab countries give military
actual battlefield military secrets to
the Soviet Union and that Israel gives
her military secrets Annabelle veal to
the United States it would be a terrific
story and it would be up-to-date thank
you okay
I haven't got that okay I turn for a
question talking about peace here in
Washington and journalists are
journalists used by government officials
here in Washington you mentioned that in
your book as well sure they are I mean
one of the problems with press reporting
and that's what people should understand
is that they are very frustrated because
people in government don't want to talk
to the press
often for a variety of reasons they want
to conceal information because it's
embarrassing because they don't want the
attention because it makes them look
unfavorable it gives it frozen
unfavorable light on their work there
are a whole host of reasons why
officials play their cards
close to the vest and journalists every
day must cope with this and it's
difficult and I don't think people
really realize that it's very hard and
the officials are often complaining
these days more and more about the media
and how they're everywhere the same
officials often want the media attention
but they want the kind of attention that
makes them look good there are also many
officials in our Congress members of
Congress in the bureaucracy who would be
happy never to see a reporter and that
is not healthy one of the things I say
in my book is one of the scandals of
press coverage I think is the lack of
coverage of local congressmen and that's
a problem there is coverage of it but
there's very little real probing that
shows people what the local congressmen
really does how they perform how they
judge by their peers that really
evaluates their performance you covered
here in Washington yes and in at home
too the same thing and let's sit let's
let's get into that more the people the
stories that are covered now are often
very self-serving and the reporters who
are forced to cover that kind of news
know that but they aren't able to go
further because they need to educate the
producers the news directors the editors
back home and that's hard and some of
those congressmen for a number of
reporters and covering news or various
issues that relate to their states or
their local areas rely on those
congressmen for a lot of sources as well
yes and therefore they there are some
restraints on them they write a story
that that's analytical that's evaluative
and they say oh boy I may lose the
source my I covered Congress myself and
my experience and it's easy for me to
say but I think it's true you may lose
them for a week or two but they'll be
back in because they need you and they
need that attention also fine if you
write a fair and objective story that
they may be unhappy about some part of
it but if they think it's fair and
objective because they're good ones and
I think to wrap up on this Carla's
question I think the officials are still
way ahead on using the press compared to
how much the press really get it and
analyzing how they perform okay let's go
down to South Pasadena California go
ahead
South Pasadena yeah I have two comments
to make I'd like a response from your
guests on both of them first of all with
regard to the media in America taken all
together as one collective thing it's an
industry it's a private industry and
it's a multi-billion dollar industry I
don't see any reason why the rules and
regulations that we monitor private
industry by for accountability purposes
should be any different for private
industry than they are for the press and
so when I hear a lot of times that press
is being a sanctioned or they're not
allowed to write what they want to write
so on and so forth because of this and
that lawsuit I don't think that that
should be something that we should take
as a threat to our freedom of speech or
anything else I think it's part of that
monitoring process that we impose on all
private industry in this country and the
second thing I wanted to say was that I
read
well I subscribe to US News and World
Report and they subscribe to the
National Review to human events to Time
Newsweek and to the New York Times and I
want to CNN and I listen to c-span quite
often have to be an uninformed person
however I do find that there are many
things that I will read in one
publication which I will not find in
other publications such as the New York
Times and so forth and I don't
understand I think the caller a ways
back who is having some difficulty
saying what he wanted to say I think he
was trying to say that if the facts are
available for anybody who wants to find
them even if we do have to go to great
lengths to find them why is it that
those facts can't be made available in
the most popular publications and on the
most popular broadcast why do we have to
go to such great lengths to find these
things thank you very much okay okay I'm
a little a loss to answer your second
question because it's pretty general it
depends on what you mean if the
facts are available sometimes I hear
people say that I hear public officials
say that I hear people on the right wing
or the left wing people who have special
interest people have access to grind and
they talk about how the press should be
more responsible that they ought to tell
us the facts and what they're really
saying often is well they ought to tell
a story the way I'd like to hear it and
that makes me nervous when we talk about
facts tell me what the facts are that
are missing and then we can talk about
that so that that question is a little
hard to answer the first point is
well-taken
yes news organizations are our
businesses - there's no question about
it they feel the same pressures they
should abide by the same rules but they
are also and they should not use their
status as a free press as a reason to
avoid doing some of the things they
should be doing on the other hand they
are not just business organizations and
everybody should understand that clearly
if we don't have a free press if we have
a press that's slowly but surely gets
its gets its freedom nibbled away its
ability to cover the stories as it
judges and not how government judges are
some special interest judges you can
take it away
take that freedom away just like that
and I think that you will be one of the
first persons that will say what
happened okay let's go to New Brunswick
New Jersey go ahead you're on c-span
what the previous caller said about the
make a point about really what all of
Free Press is is what a Free Press
really decides to print and when you
come down to it all the Free Press is is
what the Edit is the very few evidences
in this country decide to make
newsworthy what is on page one and not
page 65 and you know two-inch print and
my question is really apropos to the
previous segment about Israeli spying in
1967 you know the Israelis attacked the
United States ship USS Liberty and
international waters and
killed 34 Americans and they wounded 109
Americans now this was not an accident
because for six hours they buzzed the
ship and they knew exactly who the who
the ship belonged to and then for two
hours they attacked the ship and they
killed all this men now for 18 years
this report has been suppressed you know
for political reasons
now if the press put it in their mind to
say let's have some justice let's find
out who who's responsible for this let's
have some war crimes tribunals and let's
get down to the bottom of this we you
know we do it but because the press you
know is politically involved in too many
ways you know these these Americans
lives have just gone for naught and it's
you know it's disgusting and to make
another point I like to make another
point real quick when you know mr.
klinghoffer died you know if the
previous day the president is united you
know the previous week I would say if
the president United States had died you
know we would had a hard time kind of
making a the same opportunities of what
mr. klinghoffer did it as the president
honored state a day yes - mr.
klinghoffer was shot Jewish terrorists
in this country they killed an American
Arab and he was on page 500 in a 2-inch
print and that was it
now what's the point that's what rapido
is the power of the press is depending
on who the editors really care to print
and what they may seem to make
newsworthy okay let's stop right there
and let you have a chance to well I
think the man may have an argument he
may know something that we don't know
but I also sense the voice of a special
interest of a strong opinion here and
the journalists I know
fortunately in this country are
amazingly good at not letting their
strong opinions decide the judgments
about how news is played they may make
mistakes you may disagree with the way
they decide what gets attention and what
doesn't get attention but I want to tell
you that I am very admiring of the
journalism as a profession in this
country and the way journalists makeup
balance
judgement about a lot of the news and
you don't even know that they're doing
that and they're doing it on your behalf
what I often tell my students is let me
tell you you're the only people who make
your mistakes out in public all the time
your byline is going to be on it your
face is going to be on it everybody's
going to know it but that's okay because
you're making sound professional
judgments and you're trained to do that
and they are trained to do that okay
if you're having trouble getting through
the lines are all lit up I thought maybe
might be a quiet Christmas Eve but I see
journalism provokes a great deal of
thought and opinion I love to talk we're
gonna go now to Los Angeles you're on
the air go ahead arrogantly music
Americans both he comprises that he had
the gavel down Republican opposition
regarding the boat on the vanes on the
tax reform bill he's seen that the tape
four times I will suggest you see
another hundred times because that's not
how the way happens we don't have time
for blow-by-blow we don't have time for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that sorry up now
we're gonna let's quit we want to keep
this on the press tonight penny who says
government isn't exciting I'm not I
don't mean to cut you off but but we
don't have time tonight really to go
blow-by-blow through all of the
proceedings I think we should have
gotten you to their phone numbers and
let you talk to each other you have been
a good way to do it so let's go now to
Miami Florida go ahead you're on the job
because he voted for the AWACS for the
Arab from the Israeli Lobby and he's
written a book for 1985 and you can't
buy in the bookstore in South Florida
because there's railey Lobby has kept it
away you cry for freedom and speech and
Free Press and unbossed and everything
but when it comes to Israeli Lobby you
won't print one thing against them
people and I'd like to know why that
book has been blackballed in South
Florida I'd like an honest answer on
that thing I don't know I can't give an
honest or dishonest answer that because
I don't even know what she's talking to
no it may be that it hasn't appeared in
the bookstores or the other answer is
maybe it's all sold out I don't know
what that has to do with the press I
think it may have just been the power of
the reporting about perhaps the Israeli
Lobby they're people who feel fairly
strongly well III wouldn't agree with
that I think that you've talked to the
Israeli Lobby here in Washington you
find that they feel as strongly as you
do about the reporting and in from their
point of view okay let me tell you just
a few things that I've neglected to tell
you earlier about mr. Wolfson his
background he co-founded and directed
the graduate program of journalism at
American University for nine years
previously he was the Washington bureau
chief for the providence
journal-bulletin he's taught public
affairs the John F Kennedy School of
Government at Harvard he's an
undergraduate from Dartmouth as a
master's in journalism from Columbia
University and the second master's in
Soviet studies from Harvard so certainly
a man well qualified to talk about the
media tonight let's go now to San Bruno
California go ahead you're on c-span
Merry Christmas thank you I I just get
yellow and I hear a man like mr. Wilson
defense the press the president
ill-repute
all across this country and he should
know that there's a reason for it you
keep talking mr. Wilson about freedom of
the press
I say license is what the president
takes now and the internet with Tip
O'Neill when a congressman from the
Republican side get up asked for a boat
a point of order a Democrat high on the
Rules Committee get up and objected now
one objection stops the vote we asked
for unanimous vote to to have a recorded
vote on that I didn't read in one
newspaper and I take three of them out
here in San Francisco one newspaper tell
the truth about that now don't
continually talk about freedom of the
press
let's talk about truth of the press and
the slanted way in which they print
their stories thank you I'm not sure
that was a Merry Christmas or not yes we
don't read the same papers because what
I read seemed to explain it satisfactory
to me and I don't think it was slanted
at all it may be and I would have to go
back and look at the all the papers and
myself to see whether perhaps it was a
whether all the details were included in
all the stories myself let's go now to
Sarasota Florida you're on c-span go
ahead talk about the book tonight my
question in primary concerns is how the
media has manipulated a lot of
presidential candidates and built them
up to a position such as John Anderson's
candidacy who he was darling of the
media and Gary Hart benefited from the
media what my main question primarily
concerns about is how the media has
failed to follow up on that on election
eve
rather I need your comments on election
eve coverage of presidential candidacy
and how sometimes you see a business
review the Returns come in other times
you see a lot of background media but
not a whole lot of analysis I think
especially since they've done so well
with candidacies how come there isn't
more background on these candidate well
I'm not sure that I would agree
with that I think there is a lot of
analysis my quarrel there's a chapter in
my book where I deal with the media's
coverage of politics and elections and
Lord knows there's enough of that
coverage because it's one of the
favorite stories of the press and so
they thrust themselves into it they put
a lot of resources into it a lot of
staff and it's a heavily covered story
there is analysis my quarrel is that
there is not enough selective coverage
there's not enough of the kind of
analysis that you're talking about
consistently and it often gets lost and
buried in the minutiae and the
repetitions and the herd coverage and
that is I think the problem although I
understand your concern I just think
it's a more specific problem and I hope
that if you do get a chance to read my
book it'll come clearer to you what the
real problem is that's what I said at
the beginning of the show I think one of
the real problems is many people have a
sinister view of the press a
conspiratorial view and when they read
how things are covered and things are
decided they would see where the fault
may lie if there is fault but they would
also see where the pressures are and how
it is amazing some of the things the
press can get it okay let's go now to
Santa Monica California go ahead you're
on c-span thank you very much I'm
enjoying the program as everyone else is
doing mr. Wolfson as he wants to find
the well the rest of us seem to find the
liberal media bias is very simple all he
has to do is have his students put a
checkmark on a piece of paper every time
they hear the expression left-wing
liberal and then on an opposite column
every time they see right-wing
conservative at the end of a week or a
month you're gonna find a whole lot of
right-wing conservatives and practically
no left-wing liberal connotations
because the press assumes the right-wing
conservative but they just assumed also
there is no left-wing liberal or it
isn't referred to very often in that way
it's a simple exercise it'll prove out
in a week or a month at the most thank
you I think this is one of the great
misleading points about the press I'm
sorry I'm going to diss
agree with our caller often there are
people who think of the press being too
liberal there are political scientists
who've analyzed this and others there
have been surveys to show that
supposedly but now there is a whole body
of literature being beginning to come
out and I write about this in my book
that says this really isn't the case
that no matter how a journalist might
view things and how they might vote it
doesn't show up in the way they report
things and it is very misleading and I
think people are often barking up the
wrong tree in talking about the the
sinister supposedly liberal press in
fact there are other faults that you
should question that you should zero
into and I think that's a side road and
a false path we're gonna continue with
their calls but I want to tell you that
up next will be the US Capitol tree
lighting ceremony followed by stay tuned
for a speech by Glenn Lawrie Harvard
University professor the topic the
crisis of black America and then tonight
at 9:00 p.m. you'll find out who and who
all the c-span viewers chose as the man
of the year so if you want to find out
stay tuned until 9:00 p.m. if that's
Eastern Standard Time let's go now to
Manhattan and a call from the east go
ahead you I don't think he was fired but
his column was dropped
yes I remember his name after I said
that but you're absolutely right as
Sydney schanberg thank you for bringing
it up I think the Man of the Year
tonight it's now he ought to be Santa
Claus obviously okay let's go back
across the country probably a little bit
colder climate now we're going to
Everett Washington go ahead you're on
c-span
Louis I have a question for your guests
do you perceive the press well does your
book perceive the press as being having
a more of a right-wing slant or a
left-wing bias or being
middle-of-the-road now I'll hang up and
listen to your answer well I really
don't talk a great deal about labeling
which it is but as I just said I think
that is it is a is a false path to say I
know why there's problems with the news
media because they're too much on the
left and some people think they're too
much on the right - I think the press is
very much in the mainstream of American
life and what is nothing not understood
by people is it often reflects the
general view the majority view in the
country and in fact if you wanted to
label it I think that's where you'd put
it I think you'd put it in the middle
conservative on some things maybe
liberal on others ok and now back to
Princeton is one thing I think what's
often misunderstood is journalists and
many of the ones that I know have a
certain approach to life and to what
their work and their career and how they
cover things they have a passion for
finding out what is wrong with the world
and no one has raised this point but
often people say the press is too
negative and yes it is true journalists
look for things that are wrong because
they want to help people I mean that I
think I know people are going to
understand that and they're suspicious
of journalists but in fact the
journalists I know are very concerned
about getting at the problems finding
out what they are telling the public
what is going on so that then we can go
on and work out some solution to public
problems my book talks about the
question of whether they report enough
about Paula how policies decided and how
we decide the solutions I don't think we
do ok let's now try it again we'll go to
Princeton New Jersey go ahead hi
no Washington then I'd like to ask two
questions about aviation reporting a one
directly has to do with this sort of
heard instinct that's been mentioned
earlier in the program when covering air
crashes there doesn't seem to be as much
attention paid to some of the details
and although I will say that there has
been some we see some progress in
insofar as reporters explaining the
investigative process in this now I
would like to see what mr. Wilson thinks
about the coverage of these kinds of
disasters well you probably are up a
better up on this than I am since you
report on this or or involved in some
way I think when you get a story that
gets a lot of attention my sense of this
is when you get a story that gets a lot
of attention here then you find out a
lot about it and if it's a visible story
some will say it's a sensational story
in some cases I level at that too
but those the stories do get chronicled
do get analyzed do get investigated
others don't and that's the problem okay
let's go now to Tucson Arizona a lot of
calls from warm climates tonight this is
great
tucson arizona go ahead you're on c-span
wonderful I heard reporters awesome the
hands out hand out then the leaks and so
forth are either self-serving or or have
to do with political infighting and
maybe embarrassing somebody or you know
getting a higher position or getting rid
of somebody and it seems to me is that
if the people in the press know that the
Train they would continue to do to
report in that fashion and if I could
quickly I'd also like to say as anyone
features I am a
the grammar used in the press we saw in
Tucson in the past year or I thought a
headline that went clear across the page
a paper that said someone may have broke
the law and I was appalled and I think
that maybe journalists also might do a
little more studying to Venus Kramer one
of my students is working for the paper
out there and I'm sure she didn't write
that well we also said in defensive
reporters it could have been a
typesetter we always said that too I
think your question is very good about
handout reporting wife the reporters
know this why do they continue to do it
why do they let themselves be used and
there's a variety of reasons and we
obviously don't have the time to go into
it there are pressures to get a story to
get it in the paper or get it on
television there are economic reasons
why they have to go with things there
are reasons why their superiors see
certain kinds of stories but not others
because they don't understand what goes
on in Washington how it works there's a
lot of reasons and they are prisoners of
the system a good deal what I hope is
that they can break free and I make
recommendations in my book of ways to do
this and among them art for example to
educate editors and producers television
producers and news directors more about
how things work in Washington show them
how it works so that they get a broader
view of what goes on here and so that
their reporters here get a chance to
branch out more to get away from the
press releases the thesis of my book is
that if the press can break free of that
break free of the breaking news more and
they'll still be breaking news they'll
still be handouts then they force
officials to come out of the woodwork
more to tell more and then the public
understands better what goes on in
government that's what my book is all
about okay we're gonna yep change a call
here we're going to go to Norfolk
Virginia go ahead you're on c-span I
want to wish you Merry Christmas penny
and mr. Wilson
thank you mr. Wilson you made a
statement quite a while back that the
crime seems to be what sells newspapers
and here in Norfolk when you read the
editorial page that people keep saying
that they're tired of crime stories
because there's an awful lot of good
things going on that could be printed
and after several these letters the
editor come out and and made a big
statement that crime does sell the
newspapers but like here in Norfolk and
most cities in America where there's
only one newspaper I assume that 90% of
the newspapers are sold by home delivery
and very few were sold on the street so
how can they say that crime sells
newspaper when people automatically have
it delivered to the house and asked not
to have the crime stories and yet get it
or seem to feel that it's mandatory to
put crime on the front page well I think
it's a subtler process than that
in fact I know your paper down there I
read it sometimes when I'm down there in
the summertime and I think that there is
a temptation to go for crime there's a
knee-jerk reaction on the part of the
press to do that sort of thing but I
want to tell you you've got a lot to do
to convince me that people don't want to
read about that I think that is a
problem
I think editors have to make judgments
not to go for necessarily for it I
disagree I think people do want to read
that sort of thing and you could fill
your newspaper with that and you could
fill the Evening News with that and
often they do that for the wrong reasons
but I think that is the problem and that
editors have to say enough we have to
keep this in perspective we have to show
more about the community or it does get
distorted and I sense that you and I do
agree about that point okay we have time
for one more call this one from Santa
Rosa California go ahead good evening
thank you for a good show I had a
question I'd like to address to mr.
Wolfson regarding what seems to be a
problem when a reporter will instead of
quoting someone he's interviewing we'll
attribute of an opinion or point of view
to them I had the problem where a while
back I was
being interviewed by a reporter in my
company concerning how certain
government regulations were going to
affect our business and instead of
quoting a very short sentence but I had
to give him about a certain technical
point he decided to change the wording
around and attribute the idea in his
words to me and it and he didn't
understand the technical quality of the
issue enough to do that very well in
other words he he changed the technical
meaning of what I had to say so that I
couldn't claim it as my point of view
and it seems like I have an uncertainty
every time I read the story where a
reporter has done this as to whether I
can trust his ability to tell me what
the person's point of view is rather
than merely quoting the person okay
quick answer reporters have to
paraphrase sometimes it isn't perfect it
doesn't come out the way you like it but
boy everybody's had stories like that
done about them I've had stories done
about me that I said but I didn't say it
that way it's out of context and all
those sort of things and that's the
process unfortunately it's imperfect but
it also gets at the news in various they
get at the news in various other ways
just a real quick analysis of how you
expect journalism to change in the next
year five years to come well I'm very
optimistic and I say in my book that 25
years ago the press was at a point where
they moved from something called
objectivity which is very sterile to
interpretive reporting tell us some more
about the background the news explaining
things more I think they're now at a
take-off point where they can really get
into government reporters are brighter
than ever
editors are learning and I think the the
readers and viewers are open to this
want to know why they've got how their
government okay
thank you get it with that Lou Wilson
thank you people I'm sure we'll look
forward to reading your book the
untapped power of the press do all of
you have a very very happy holiday
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
for more information about this program
please feel free to write us at c-span
400 North Capitol Street Northwest suite
one five five Washington DC - zero zero
zero one
[Music]